I was browsing our reddit discussion
forum this morning it's the best place
to talk directly to over 4,000 of our
viewers and listeners and Pat is on the
reddit and I am on the reddit at david
pakman.com slash reddit spotted some
interesting discussions and posts that I
wanted to run by you quickly before we
move on with the program starting with a
post about the new round of Clinton
inspired attacks on Bernie Sanders this
story which we covered yesterday the
excerpt of Hillary Clinton's new book
which in in many areas go after Bernie
Sanders sometimes unfairly sometimes a
little bit less unfairly we're not
missed by our audience who started a
discussion about that a really good
discussion I encourage you to
participate in also on our reddit
discussion forum a suggestion for a deep
dive long-form video US military
influence US military influence in a
number of different ways and I think
this is actually an idea that could go
in very different directions US military
influence on everyday life is one thing
US military influence on geopolitical
situations I think there's a lot of ways
that we can talk about American military
influence because that influence is
quite widespread defense contractors
politicians this could actually be quite
a few long-form pieces yeah military
industrial complex sure also from our
reddit discussion forum a suggestion for
how David might get on the Joe Rogan
experience this is interesting we've
been talking about how it would be great
publicity for me to get on the Joe Rogan
program although it's pretty tough to
get on it seems he doesn't like being
told on Twitter to interview people and
there's not really public contact
information for the show and what
someone suggested on the reddit is if I
can get myself on the Josh Zepps show
that Joe Rogan apparently is a fan of
Josh Zepps huh and thus might hear about
me that way
I don't know well you'll have to do well
on that program so I would have to
pressure would be on if I was
embarrassed I probably would not get an
invite on Joe Rogan's program also on
our reddit discussion forum David Pakman
dominates the front page of Reddit svit
it two days ago I got a message from a
friend saying you were on the front page
of Reddit right now
like not the david pakman show subreddit
but like the front page of Reddit and I
said really it's been we've been on
vacation I don't know that what it would
be for and it was a four year old video
I did after I was incorrectly included
in a documentary about bullied gay teens
who had committed suicide and I did a
video saying you know despite being
featured in this video in this
documentary I am not dead I am NOT a
teen I was not bullied and I'm not gay
and the video did well four years ago
but then somehow it made it to the front
page after one of our reddit users
gigantic meaty balls posted it to Reddit
and it did incredibly well so that was
an interesting thing and not the first
time I was misidentified I've also been
misidentified as you can see in this
screenshot from headline news from dr.
Drew's program which I think no longer
exists I was once identified as frank
mink former neo-nazi and of course we
now know Frank we interviewed him on the
program last week so an eventful week on
Reddit that's an interesting way to
become friends to me I'm one you were
misidentified them yessum especially
when they're a former neo-nazi
especially and I think lastly do we have
one more thread to show people yes we do
are there going to be more live shows we
had a nearly month-long break from my
youtube live streams which take place
sporadically in the evenings and the
vacation and a lot of hectic stuff
including me starting the semester
teaching at Boston College got in the
way of live streams but I did one last
night and I hope to I hope to livestream
again if asked and I've been asked I
will live stream again so join our
reddit david pakman.com slash read it